we have two huge massive breaking news
stories on the deep state one how
incontrovertible exculpatory evidence
was purposely withheld from the FISA
Court the evidence is in that
blockbuster news and Peter Struck's
hidden testimony released tonight we've
got all the details we begin with other
news the system was rigged now countless
students who apply to Georgetown USC
Stanford Yale all these other top
universities we're likely cheated out of
their spot because in this case it is a
zero-sum game all because dozens perhaps
now as many as 800 I'm reading a wealthy
family selfishly made massive payments
to this man right here named Rick singer
in order to fix an SAT score bribe
official College Board's people and
steel spots reserved for student
athletes they never played the sport
they even went as far as to photoshop
the pictures of the faces of these kids
and put them on the bodies of the real
athletes that's how far this one now a
five million dollar class-action lawsuit
has been filed against eight of these
universities on the basis that certain
students were cheated out of a spot
because of the university's failure to
prevent the scam others are claiming
well damages asserting that their
Stanford University degrees have been
irreparably damaged and devalued either
way this is not a good look for some of
America's quote prestigious universities
which allowed massive corruption of
fester at some of the highest levels now
one of the most notable people charged
in this ongoing scandal was Full House
actress Lori Loughlin as you can see
they're paying five hundred thousand
dollars in bribes to fraudulently secure
spots at USC for her two daughters and
when Laughlin was arrested well one of
her daughters apparently was spending
our Spring Break onboard a yacht owned
by us C's Board of Trustees Chairman
rich Caruso the system in this case
appears to be rigged we give every
person the presumption of innocence but
think about the people that work hard
the students that study they get the A's
play by the rules earn them then
you have a bunch of people only care
about status and bragging rights and
those spots are taken we'll have more on
this later tonight but first we have
other breaking news out of Chicago
before we get to our top story just as
Jesse Smollett was back in court today
he pled not guilty to those 16 felony
charges stemming from an elaborate hate
crime hoax scheme and found guilty
smaller could face up to 48 years in
prison forced to pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars in fines
this comes as we're now learning that a
former top aide to former first lady
Michelle Obama urged the Chicago Police
Department to turn over the case to the
FBI and of course that never happened
and now all eyes are directly on
Smollett who was allegedly defrauding
the city of Chicago from the very
beginning all while dragging Trump
supporters through the mud now before we
get to our top story I want to focus on
hannity watch the radical 2020
democratic candidates yet another
Democrat has jumped into the race this
case being former congressman robert
Francis bozo or Roarke well that's why I
called flailing his way into the race
this week literally telling Vanity Fair
that he was born to run for president
how regal needless to say bozo got off
to a hot start in Iowa take a look this
country did the challenges have never
been greater more severe on the more
humorous side speaker Pelosi was
actually asked today to name bozos
greatest accomplishments during his time
there in the house well let's say it was
a struggle for the speaker to take a
look what in your view was better or
worse signature accomplishment as a
member of the House there was a broad
retail vitality to the Congress one of
the issues in his as I haven't been
asked this question but I just know of
his record here and when he came he came
as a real champion for
like he got a great deal of support from
the environmental community in his
district also he's a member of the Armed
Services Committee a strong member of
Down Services Committee now too bad all
that vitality didn't help bozo achieve
anything during his time in Washington
but get ready
if bozo is elected he plans to flush the
Constitution down the toilet like so
many other 2020 radical extreme
Democratic socialists and he wants to
pack the Supreme Court in other words
they want to increase the number of
Court justices illegally reshape the
court we're gonna have more in a mini
monologue featuring everything you no
need to know about robert Francis
O'Rourke that the left-wing destroy hate
Trump media mob will never tell you
including the time he almost killed
somebody during a DUI hit-and-run
incident and we'll show you what
President Trump has to say about well
bozos decision to run now without a
doubt Democrats are willing to do
anything and everything to be President
Trump even apparently giving young kids
16 the right to vote take a look I
myself have always been furloughing
voted the voting age to 16 I think it's
really important to capture kids when
they're in high school when they're
interested in all of this when they're
learning about government to be able to
vote maybe we should make it the legal
drinking age
all right well more on this radical way
the Democrats are trying to reshape
America very dangerous times first let's
get to our top story major huge breaking
news we begin our Hannity watch tonight
on the deep state Trump Russia collusion
is has always been and remains a myth
and the highest ranking member of the
FBI knew it breaking just moments ago
according to the hills John Solomon who
will join us in a minute there is now
evidence that the Trump campaign
associates George papadopolis and Carter
Paige both made exculpatory statements
at the very beginning the very start of
the FBI's Russia probe back in 2016 now
according to Solomon both men made
comments to the FBI informant Stefan
halper making it clear they were never
involved they
had no knowledge of any collusion
whatsoever zero nothing the FBI press
forward anyway possibly hiding thatx
culpa Tory evidence from the
all-important FISA Court where he know
of fraud was committed in fact CalPERS
account was never presented to the court
that's FISA abuse that's fraud before a
FISA Court that's prosecutorial
misconduct that is an effort by a few
high-ranking bureaucrats to undermine
Donald Trump and his allies and frankly
help steal an election
it's the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in modern history
and it is now the house of cards is
beginning to fall tonight we have other
major breaking news last week it was
Bruce or last night it was Lisa page now
we have the full transcript from Peter
structs testimony on the hill again
courtesy Georgia congressman Collins
thank you this is a huge development for
context let's remember Peter struck
violently anti-trump Pro Hillary Clinton
FBI investigator he's involved in every
single role here every integral role in
both the FBI's Clinton investigation
wait a minute matter and the subsequent
probe into the Trump campaign and struck
helped author Hillary's exoneration
letter and he was among the agents who
later interviewed Hillary he says he
knew he was in the room when they took
out the words from the DOJ Oh gross
negligence the legal standard Oh
reckless disregard
and remember they added the new stature
of intent lisa page told us last night
this went right into Loretta Lynch's
office all of it what did she know when
did she know it what did she tell Obama
what did he know when did he know it and
at the same time he was texting his FBI
girlfriend Lisa page that Hillary would
win and should win a hundred million a
zero Trump supporters were smelly
Walmart people that Trump was deplorable
even vowed to stop Trump and so much
more we are talking about hundreds of
graphic anti Trump Pro Hillary texts and
now according to struck sworn testimony
we now know that Obama's DOJ led by
Loretta
corroborating the testimony ELISA Paige
entered into an agreement with the FBI
actually restricting the FBI access to
Hillary Clinton's emails during their
so-called investigation including emails
related to the Clinton Foundation and
according to struck I'll quote him my
recollection is that access to those
emails were based on consent that was
negotiated between the Department of
Justice attorneys and the counsels for
Clinton puts a lot of light on that
tarmac meeting with Bill and Loretta
Lynch doesn't it and struck even
commented that there was an even an
extensive filter team in place to work
through the various consent agreements
with team Clinton in other words let me
break it down the FBI's investigation
was controlled from the very top of
Obama's Department of Justice let me say
it again the top in other words this was
never a real investigation the people
involved in it are now telling us in
other words it's now gone from Oh Peter
struck Lisa Paige call me McCabe and and
others too Oh Loretta Lynch herself to
the head of the DOJ the outcome they
made sure was never in doubt now wonder
if Roger stone got a consent agreement
when the FBI raided his house pre-dawn
raid would you know navy frogs and
amphibious vehicles and sixteen vehicles
and 27 men armed you know in the dark at
night pre-dawn raid but CNN cameras
meanwhile struck also confirmed that the
language and Clinton's exoneration
letter was in fact changed as I said
from gross negligence which is the legal
definition in the law they changed it to
extreme carelessness at the behest again
of the DOJ and their attorneys who are
working for Loretta Lynch on behalf
clearly of Hillary Clinton struck
testified my recollection is attorneys
brought it up and that these of course
with DOJ attorneys this is yet more
damning evidence that Obama's DOJ
literally rigged the investigation
from the beginning so that Hillary
Clinton could continue as a presidential
candidate when even the number one
general counsel the FBI argued she
should be charged with the felony of the
Espionage Act they guaranteed that she
can continue without facing any criminal
charges or as Lindsey Graham put it
earlier today on the Senate floor anyone
else
you me everybody else we don't have dual
justices under the law in this country
anymore we'd be in jail take a look how
do you interview Clinton the way she was
interviewed any American out there who
did what Secretary Clinton did you'd be
in jail now we let Muller look at all
things Trump related to collusion and
otherwise somebody needs to look at what
happened on the other side and find out
if the FBI and the DOJ had two systems
one supporting the person they wanted to
win a one out to get the person they
wanted to lose some of these people have
been fired for lying and it's now time
to have a special counsel look in all
things 2016 not just Trump
well said Senator Graham good for you if
America has eight equal justice under
the law system equal application under
our laws a special counsel into the
Clintons crimes that were rigged will be
appointed by the new Attorney General
immediately and of course while the FBI
gave Hillary a free pass Muller's
Special Counsel investigation and of the
Trump campaign that was tainted we now
know from the get-go
from day one from the beginning remember
when struck texted that his work on the
Russia collusion investigation remember
was an insurance policy well he couldn't
really explain any of that away the
excuses were beyond weak and pathetic
obviously he had incentive to take down
Trump at all cost
remember Hillary should win a hundred
million is zero when robert muller
appointed him as a lead investigator and
a special counsel probe was he ever
asked about his obvious political bias
no accordian instructs testimony never
Muller didn't care
didn't inquire about the known political
bias and
investigation into a political campaign
that's probably why I've been warning
everybody about Muller and he hired of
course Hillary Clinton's former Clinton
Foundation attorney jeanne ray or the
fact that Andrew Weissman actually
attended Hillary Clinton's election
night party that never happened but
breaking tonight in a sign that we are
nearing the end of the witch-hunt Andrew
Weissman is now stepping away from team
Muller maybe time to investigate him I
guess he's not happy that the witch-hunt
is going to come up short of their goal